one of my arguments has been the
Commission it is a 60s gimmick sitcom
that's been updated for the 2010s the
premise of unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
is that Kimmy Schmidt herself was in a
bunker for many many years after she was
rescued she decides she's going to stay
in New York City she's gone from this
world of just terrible terrible trauma
to a world where everything is bursting
with new opportunity and the color
represents that in many ways television
has had color since the 60s but it's one
of those things where a lot of shows
haven't had time to really build out
color palettes now we've had some great
shows with lots of color and then
Pushing Daisies is one that comes to
mind there's a show where everything in
it was color-coordinated that's from
creator Bryan Fuller who frequently does
such things he also does tremendous work
with color on Hannibal where he uses
rich blood reds to accent the the scenes
of death and horror
kimmy schmitt definitely wants to signal
to you that this is taking place in a
weird heightened world Kimmy and Titus
the roommates they're both often colored
and just very bright accent colors that
stand out from the rest of the scene war
if you look carefully are often
color-coordinated with the sets and with
the props that are around them another
example would be Jacqueline who's the
woman that Kimmy works for she's very
often dressed in whites beiges things
that sort of blend in with her
environment she is a woman who is from
the very rich upper-class world and so
she of course doesn't want to rock the
boat too much and her color reflects
that and finally the guy that kidnapped
Kimmy is always in very white and black
tones the sort of represents I think
kind of his religious worldview but it
also represents the fact that he's
trying to drag Kimmy back to a world of
monochrome I think episode 6 in general
is really interesting in terms of color
coordination when Kimmy is at school
where she's trying to get her GED from a
teacher who just doesn't care he's again
dressed in sort of the colors of white
of
age the monochrome is sort of the-- the
hue of the people who are trying to keep
Kimmy down on this show
where's Kimmy stressed in a very bright
green that contrasts well with the green
of the blackboards and you know sort of
contrasts well with everybody around her
this is a show that I think has a couple
of small issues here and there but it's
definitely a show that by the end of
season one I was very much into I just
really want to spend more time in this
world because it's so interesting and
colorful and unlike anything else on
television